OK, let's unpack this.
Have you ever found yourself
wondering why certain global
conflicts seem to drag on
indefinitely, even when the
human suffering they inflict is
utterly immense?
Yeah, it's a tough question.
We often discuss the devastating
costs of war, but what if a
nation, a powerful nation, could
engage in conflict without its
own people truly feeling the
direct, visceral pain?
You mean like insulating the
home front?
Exactly what if the heaviest
price was paid somewhere else by
others far from home, creating a
kind of geopolitical
invisibility cloak?
Today, we're diving deep into a
topic that shines A harsh light
on precisely this paradox proxy
wars and their unsettling,
almost chilling ability to evade
traditional forms of
accountability.
What's truly fascinating here, I
think, is how the very nature of
conflict itself has undergone A
profound evolution over time.
It really has changed.
How so?
Well, this evolution has created
a new sophisticated kind of
insulation for those who support
these conflicts from a distance.
It's a mechanism that subtly
shifts the burden of war and
critically, fundamentally alters
the landscape of accountability,
right?
And for this deep dive, where
are we drawing our insights
from?
Our core insights today are
drawn from a truly powerful and
thought provoking piece by Chris
Abraham, aptly titled The
Perfect Crime, Why Proxy Wars
Evade Accountability.
The perfect crime.
Wow, that title alone really
makes you stop and think.
It does.
It grabs you.
Our mission in this deep dive,
then, is to go beyond the
headlines and truly understand
why these specific types of
conflicts are so incredibly
difficult to hold accountable.
What exactly makes them the
perfect crime in the complex
modern geopolitical arena?
And perhaps most importantly,
what all that means for you, the
global citizen, in grasping the
often brutal and deeply complex
dynamics of Modern Warfare?
It's about recognizing the
underlying structures, really
the structures, that allow these
seemingly intractable conflicts
to persist, and how they subtly
reshape our understanding of
war, peace, and responsibility.
OK, so where do we start?
How does Abraham build his case?
Well, he starts from a very
personal place.
Chris Abraham, the author of our
source material, brings a unique
and deeply personal perspective
to this entire discussion, which
for me really lends incredible
weight to his arguments.
He reveals that he was born in
March 1970.
Right in the thick of it.
Right, placing his earliest
years squarely in the midst of
the Vietnam War, a conflict that
officially lasted until 1975, he
states, and I'm quoting him
directly here.
My earliest years unfolded
during the Vietnam War.
I grew up under the shadow of
that conflict and lived through
every major war since the first
Gulf War, 9/11, Iraq,
Afghanistan, Syria and countless
covert operations funded through
black budgets.
That's quite a list.
A lifetime shaped by conflict,
essentially.
It really is.
He's not just listing historical
events.
He emphasizes that he has seen
both the times of war and the
uneasy stretches of peace in
between.
And you can feel that weight in
his writings.
Think about that for a moment.
A lifetime spent observing,
sometimes first hand, sometimes
from afar, the relentless cycles
of conflict and their profound
societal impact.
This is an abstract theory for
him.
It's, you know, lived
experience.
Absolutely.
And this personal history is far
more than just an interesting
anecdote that frames our
discussion.
It establishes A foundational
and deeply visceral
understanding of what a truly
costly war felt like
domestically for American
Society.
Right, the feeling of it.
Exactly.
It provides an immediate and
very direct comparison point for
what happens when that domestic
cost, that undeniable human
toll, is effectively removed or,
you know, cleverly masked from
the equation.
So his experience gives him a
baseline.
Precisely.
Abraham's lived experience with
wars that deeply impacted the
home front serves as the
Crucible against which he
measures today's conflicts.
He understands fundamentally
what it means for society to pay
a price in blood, sweat and
tears for a war, and how that
personal sacrifice translates
into political will or
conversely, powerful anti war
sentiment.
OK, so let's really reflect on
Vietnam through Abraham's lens,
because he paints a very vivid
picture.
He notes it.
It was a war that Americans
could not ignore.
Couldn't ignore, that's key.
Because they were the ones
dying.
He highlights how protests had
weight because they were rooted
in a shared national grief.
A.
Shared grief?
That's powerful.
Imagine, if you can, the
pervasive, almost suffocating
impact of each draft lottery,
where young men's futures, their
education, their careers, their
very lives were decided by the
spin of a wheel and a random
number.
The randomness must have been
terrifying for families.
Absolutely.
And picture the heartbreaking,
all too frequent sight of each
coffin draped with a flag, being
returned home, not to a remote
military base, but often
directly to small towns and
suburban neighborhoods.
Bringing the war right to the
doorstep.
Forcing the entire country,
every community, to reckon with
the war's cost.
It wasn't an abstract debate
discussed in Washington.
It was a daily, painful reality
for families across the nation.
The pain was real, immediate
and, crucially, unavoidable, as
he says.
It forced difficult
conversations at dinner tables
and on street corners.
You couldn't just tune it out.
Which brings us to an incredibly
important question for us to
consider.
What was it specifically about
Vietnam that made public
protests so undeniably powerful,
so effective in driving
governmental change?
He's a very direct answer for
that, doesn't.
He he does.
Abraham makes it abundantly
clear, and his words resonate
deeply.
My mother's protest was not
about abstract morality.
Not just ideals.
It was about stopping the
killing of people's own sons.
This phrase encapsulates the
core of it, this immediate,
visceral and deeply personal
connection to domestic
suffering.
Your own kids.
Your neighbors.
Exactly.
The constant, terrifying risk to
1's own children, one's own
neighbors, one's own community
provided an undeniable,
unshakable anchor for anti war
sentiment.
An anchor.
I like that, that metaphor.
It was a shared national trauma
that unified dissent and gave it
an irrefutable moral and
political force.
The blood spilled was their
blood.
The lives lost were their lives.
And that truth was simply
impossible for political leaders
to ignore or dismiss for long.
It wasn't just about policy.
No, it was about protecting your
own deeply personal.
But if Vietnam was, as we've
just explored, profoundly
defined by this unavoidable and
pervasive domestic pain, what
about conflicts today?
What is fundamentally shifted in
the way we as societies
experience and react to war?
Well, that's the crux of his
argument about the present.
The author makes a stark and
rather unsettling argument that
today's protests for Palestine,
for Ukraine, are easier to
dismiss.
Easier to dismiss.
Why?
And the crucial question he
poses is why?
Why are these movements, even
when passionate and widespread,
often marginalized or swept
aside by the political
establishment and mainstream
media?
And his answer is.
Because, as he starkly puts it
in these are truly powerful
words, no American children are
dying in those conflicts.
That's blunt.
It's a harsh truth, but it's
absolutely central to his
argument that the domestic price
of war, lack thereof, dictates
the political leverage of
protest.
Right.
So if we connect this to the
broader geopolitical picture,
this fundamental absence of
direct domestic casualties
profoundly alters the nature of
public engagement.
How people get involved or
don't.
Exactly and critically, the
perception and efficacy of
public dissent demonstrators for
these contemporary causes,
whether it's for the
humanitarian crisis in Palestine
or the existential struggle in
Ukraine, according to the
source, are painted as naive,
radical or ideological.
Labels.
Easy labels.
Yes, and this isn't just an
accusation, it's a strategic
narrative.
They become easier targets for
dismissal because, as Abraham
argues, there is no domestic
roof to anchor their 'cause.
That anchor is gone.
Right when it is someone else's
war, a conflict where your sons
and daughters are not on the
front lines, where flags aren't
being folded for your fallen
neighbors, it is easier to label
the protest as fringe.
So the protests lack that
visceral weight.
Precisely this highlights a
monumental and deeply troubling
shift in how public dissent is
not only perceived by the powers
that be, but, more
strategically, how it can be so
effectively sidelined and
delegitimized by political
actors.
The emotional anchor is gone,
and with it much of the
traditional, undeniable public
pressure that once shaped
wartime policy.
So if that vital anchor of
domestic grief is missing, if
protests can be so easily
dismissed precisely because the
profound pain of conflict is
felt elsewhere, what does this
all mean for the very concept of
accountability in Modern
Warfare?
It leads directly into a central
thesis.
It genuinely feels like the very
mechanism that once held power
to account the direct,
undeniable human cost has been
eroded, paving the way for
something Abraham calls.
The perfect crime.
Here's where it gets really
interesting and, frankly, quite
chilling.
As Abraham introduces this core
concept, the author delivers a
powerful, almost provocative
statement.
Proxy wars are the perfect
crime.
Not crime in the usual sense,
but politically.
Right.
He's not talking about
traditional criminal acts
committed by individuals, but
rather a sophisticated
geopolitical maneuver.
He then goes on to explain their
core, almost ingenious
advantage.
They allow nations to fight
without feeling the pain of
fighting.
Think about that fighting
without pain.
At least not your pain.
Think about the sheer strategic
benefit of that for a moment.
The ability to achieve
significant geopolitical
objectives, to exert influence
to counter rivals, all without
incurring the crushing domestic
human cost.
The cost that has historically
been the greatest, most potent
constraint on warfare for a
democratic state.
Exactly what's truly fascinating
here is how this concept
contrasts so sharply with
historical turning points that
we've seen throughout history.
Would direct costs forced
reevaluation?
Like the ones he mentioned
earlier.
Exactly.
The source specifically mentions
Vietnam and Algeria, two major
conflicts that turned when the
occupiers own people bled.
Bleeding at home, forced to
change.
In both cases, it was the
direct, undeniable and mounting
casualties on the home front
that eventually forced the
occupying powers to reconsider
their involvement and ultimately
withdraw.
That direct human cost was not
just a factor, it was the
catalyst for fundamental policy
change.
Couldn't be sustained
politically.
Right.
Proxy wars, by their very
design, seek to eliminate that
pressure point entirely.
They are engineered to ensure
that the blood and sacrifice are
outsourced, externalized.
First, on to someone else.
Keeping the occupier, or rather
the supporting power, insulated
and politically safe from the
blowback of human loss.
But he suggests this didn't
happen overnight.
Right?
There were steps along the way.
Yes, exactly.
Before we delve deeper into the
perfect crime as it manifests
today, the author points to
earlier developments, almost
stepping stones that gradually
LED towards this ultimate
insulation.
OK, what were those?
He contrasts Vietnam and
Algeria, where direct casualties
were so pivotal, with Iraq and
Afghanistan, noting they were
different.
They were fought by volunteers,
not conscripts.
The shift to the All Volunteer
Force.
Right.
And this shift, while seemingly
benign, perhaps even seen as a
positive move away from forced
service, actually had profound
implications for public
engagement and the political
cost of war.
So what was the key?
The implication of dropping the
draft.
This raises an important
question.
What exactly was the implication
of this shift away from a
universal conscription or draft
system?
The source states unequivocally,
without a draft, the public felt
detached.
Detached.
That makes sense.
It wasn't everyone's potential
problem anymore.
Precisely.
This detachment wasn't merely
psychological, it had very real
political consequences.
The wars dragged on because they
cost the public little in terms
of direct human sacrifice.
Because the burden was
concentrated.
Exactly.
In a volunteer army, the burden
of war is concentrated on
comparatively small, dedicated
segment of the population and
their families.
The vast majority of citizens go
about their daily lives largely
untouched by the conflict.
So the shared experience was
lost.
Largely, yes.
While there were still
casualties and the national
grief for fallen soldiers was
very real, it didn't permeate
every household and community in
the same pervasive way a draft
era war would.
It created a growing chasm
between the military and
civilian populations.
A crucial step towards
insulation, even if not the
final form.
Yes, a crucial, if perhaps
unintended step towards
insulating the broader public
from the direct personal costs
of conflict.
Even if it wasn't yet the full
proxy war model, the public
could mostly turn away or
engages observers rather than
participants with skin in the
game.
OK, so that's the volunteer army
face.
Then.
Abraham argues that Ukraine
takes this one step further,
representing, in his view, the
epitome of this installation.
The ultimate evolution, perhaps?
He details the Western
involvement in this ongoing,
devastating conflict.
The West supplies weapons,
intelligence and money, but not
bodies.
No boots on the ground from the
supporting nations.
That's the key.
This is the core mechanism of
the modern proxy war in action,
where the support is
substantial, often decisive, yet
the ultimate human sacrifice,
the direct loss of life, is
borne by others.
And this is also where concepts
like black budgets become
relevant, right Funding that
avoids public scrutiny.
Absolutely.
Funds allocated with minimal
public scrutiny, effectively
allowing for substantial
financial backing without
transparent public debate on the
full scope of involvement.
This is precisely where the
brutal efficiency of the modern
proxy war becomes chillingly
clear.
As the source highlights,
Ukrainians and Russians die by
the hundreds of thousands, while
NATO nations avoid casualties.
The scale of death is immense
just elsewhere.
Exactly.
The domestic impact on the
supporting nations is virtually
non existent in terms of human
lives.
There are no folded flags
delivered to suburban doorsteps,
no soldiers at the door bearing
devastating news.
That image of the folded flag?
It's so powerful because it
represents that direct,
unbearable cost.
And its absence is just as
significant.
This profound absence of direct
visceral pain means that for the
insulated societies providing
support, the war is just a
distant moral debate.
Something on the news not in
your neighborhood.
Right.
It's something discussed on
cable news, debated in political
circles, perhaps a topic for
protests, but it doesn't
manifest as a deeply personal
tragedy for the average citizen.
It creates a critical, almost
surgical disconnect between the
rhetoric of support and the
reality of the immense suffering
on the ground.
Absolutely.
When you think about the scale
of military aid, I mean the
provision of advanced missile
systems like Hamars, or vast
sums and financial assistance or
the sharing of real time
satellite intelligence, this is
an immense commitment.
Huge resources are being poured
in yet.
Because that commitment doesn't
translate into domestic
casualties for the supporting
nations, the perception of cost
remains minimal.
It's managed.
And the author sees a similar
dynamic elsewhere too.
He does.
He sees a very similar pattern
unfolding in Israeli war in
Gaza, though he notes with
different stakes, primarily
referencing the nature of the
conflict and the direct parties
involved.
But the principle of outsource
suffering applies.
Yes, here to the profound human
cost is geographically
contained, as the casualties are
Palestinian and Israeli, not
American or European.
This geographic and national
separation of casualties from
supporting nations seems to be a
recurring, almost defining
feature of what Abraham calls
the perfect crime.
So the support flows, but the
sacrifice doesn't fall.
Exactly this dynamic means that
Western support comes without
Western sacrifice.
And this is the crux of why
protests abroad, even if
passionate and widespread, often
have diminished force or are
easily dismissed.
Because there's no blood price
being paid at home.
Right.
They can be painted as naive or
extreme because no one at home
is paying the price in blood.
This consistent pattern, evident
across these contemporary
conflicts, shows how the
outsourcing of suffering is not
merely a side effect, but a
deliberate, strategic and
defining feature of modern proxy
conflicts.
That's part of the design.
It allows for a sustained
engagement for the achievement
of strategic goals, whether it's
weakening arrival, projecting
influence or supporting an ally,
all with without the traditional
domestic political backlash
associated with high casualties.
The cost is.
Externalized and the
accountability along with it.
And with it, the pressure for
accountability is significantly
reduced.
This also allows for plausible
deniability.
On some level.
You can deny direct involvement
because your boots aren't on the
ground even as your weapons and
intelligence are deciding the
conflicts trajectory.
So if the profound human cost of
conflict isn't born at home, if
the traditional mechanisms for
generating public pressure are
effectively circumvented, what
does this truly unsettling
development mean for the future
of democratic accountability,
and indeed for how wars
themselves are waged by powerful
nations?
It raises some very serious
questions about democratic
control.
It seems to enable an entirely
new paradigm of perpetual
conflict, where the true
suffering is out of sight, out
of mind for the decision makers
and the public funding it.
Which leads directly to the
consequences he outlines.
This brings us directly to what
our source identifies as the
core danger of proxy wars.
And it's profound one.
This is why proxy wars are so
dangerous.
They are insulated from
democratic pressure.
That insulation is the key
danger.
In a functioning democracy,
public opinion, particularly
when fueled by shared sacrifice
and direct human cost, it's
supposed to be a crucial check
on state power, especially when
it comes to the gravest decision
a nation can make going to war.
The ultimate check, arguably.
But here Abraham argues that
fundamental check is missing.
It's been bypassed.
What's fascinating and deeply
concerning here is precisely how
effectively these conflicts
bypass the traditional
mechanisms that have
historically forced a public
reckoning with the true cost of
war.
What mechanism specifically?
The source highlights what's
utterly absent.
They require no draft, no mass
funerals, no national reckoning.
All the things that made Vietnam
so different.
Exactly.
Think about the historical power
of each of those elements.
A draft forces every family to
consider their direct stake in
the conflict, making war a
personal rather than abstract
concern.
Mass funerals bring the cost
home in the most visceral,
heartbreaking way, impossible to
ignore.
And a national reckoning like
the one we saw after Vietnam
forces a society to grapple with
moral and strategic failures,
leading to profound
introspection and policy shifts.
These are the pressure points.
Yes, these are the very pressure
points that in the past have
often compelled governments to
reevaluate their commitments or
indeed, to end conflicts that
were proving too costly to the
Homefront.
Without them, the political
landscape shifts dramatically.
Allowing decisions with less
overseed.
Allowing for decisions to be
made with a kind of internal
impunity.
Unity you could say.
And without those internal
pressure points, without that
shared national grief and direct
human cost, the chilling
implication Abraham raises is
that proxy wars can continue
indefinitely.
Indefinitely.
That's a terrifying prospect.
It's an almost terrifying
thought, a perpetual state of
conflict that never quite
reaches a true resolution
because the traditional impetus
for one, the domestic backlash,
is always just out of reach.
Right.
If we connect this to the bigger
picture, it's all about the
perceived cost from the
perspective of the supporting
nation's decision makers and its
public.
How they see the cost?
Precisely these conflicts
continue because they cost only
and rhetoric to the societies
behind them.
This perception of a low
domestic cost, measured in terms
of lives and direct suffering,
is what makes these conflicts
seem endlessly sustainable for
those pulling the levers of
power and funding them.
Even if the real cost on the
ground is horrific.
Exactly.
Even if the actual human cost in
the proxy theater is absolutely
astronomical, as we've
discussed, millions displaced,
economy shattered, generations
traumatized, that devastation is
entirely outsourced.
Out of sight, out of mind.
From the vantage point of the
decision makers and the public
in the supporting nation, the
Ledger looks remarkably clean.
This creates an environment
where long term low stakes for
them.
Engagement becomes the norm,
despite the incredible human
tragedy unfolding far away.
It's a stark illustration of how
economic cost, while
significant, is often
politically more palatable than
human casualties.
Much more palatable, definitely.
The author also points out how
modern proxy wars go beyond
earlier methods of public
shielding that we've seen
implemented in previous
conflicts.
He mentions techniques like
embedding journalists, hiding
casualty numbers, relying on
drones.
Right attempts to manage the
narrative.
These were always clearly to try
and dull the public's perception
of the human cost, to make war
seem less messy or less deadly.
But he argues proxy wars are
different, fundamentally
different.
So this raises an important
question.
How do proxy wars differ
fundamentally from these earlier
attempts at insulating the
public from the grim realities
of conflict?
What's the core difference?
The source clarifies that those
older methods, while
manipulative and designed to
control the narrative, only
dulled the pain.
They blurred the edges, soften
the blow, but the pain was still
there, however muted or delayed.
Still perceptible.
In contrast, proxy wars
eliminated entirely for the
supporting nation.
This is why they are described
in such start terms.
They are clean, bloodless at
home and thus endlessly
sustainable.
Clean only for the side not
doing the bleeding.
Exactly.
And then, in a truly powerful
concluding statement, he says
they are, in the coldest sense,
the perfect crime.
Wow.
This highlights a significant
and disturbing progression in
the ability of nations to
completely externalize the human
cost of conflict, removing it
from their own societal
consciousness and accountability
mechanisms.
It's like perfecting the art of
war without consequences for the
sponsor.
It's a method of warfare
designed to avoid the internal
reckoning that has historically
brought conflicts to an end.
It allows strategic objectives
to trump domestic consequence in
a way rarely seen before.
If accountability is so
effectively evaded and the pain
of war is so thoroughly
outsourced, what does that mean
for the very possibility of
achieving lasting peace or
genuine resolution in these
conflicts?
That's the $1,000,000 question,
isn't it?
It certainly suggests a future
where for some, war becomes an
eternal cost free exercise, at
least from their insulated
vantage point, which leads to
the moral dimension.
Yes, moral vacuum, as he puts
it.
So if societies that support
proxy wars are effectively
insulated from the true human
cost, what does that imply for
the very nature of winning a
conflict?
Abraham states quite bluntly.
Wars like these cannot be won
through hearts and minds.
Which seems counterintuitive to
a lot of modern thinking about
conflict resolution.
Right, it seems to fly in the
face of traditional
counterinsurgency theory, or
even just basic human empathy
and community building in
conflict zones where engaging
the local population is often
seen as paramount to long term
success.
So why can't they be one that
way, According to him?
What's fascinating here is the
precise reason Abraham provides
for this profound found
disconnect.
Because the hearts and minds
funding them are never at risk.
The funders hearts and minds are
safe.
Exactly.
This creates A fundamental and
profound moral vacuum.
The decision makers, the
strategic planners and the
broader public in the supporting
nations don't bear the personal
burden of death, displacement or
daily terror that defines the
lives of those directly caught
in the proxy conflict.
That detachment again.
This detachment, this lack of
personal risk, in turn,
profoundly diminishes the
imperative to truly engage with
the human element of the
conflict on the ground, to
understand the local
population's grievances, to
build trust, or to foster
genuine reconciliation.
So hearts and minds becomes a
slogan, not a strategy.
Rooted and shared risk.
Pretty much, the concept of
winning hearts and minds becomes
irrelevant or at best a
secondary concern when your own
hearts and minds, your domestic
public, are not invested in the
same way.
The primary goal becomes
achieving strategic objectives
for the external power.
Rather than fostering stability
or legitimacy within the proxy
state itself.
The source goes on to highlight
what he sees as the stark moral
consequence of this entire
system.
The suffering is outsourced to
those with no choice and no
voice.
That's a devastating line.
It's a powerful and deeply
disturbing image, the immense
burden of conflict falling
disproportionately and entirely
on those who often have no say
in its beginning, its
continuation, or its eventual
agonizing end.
It's almost as if the collateral
damage is precisely the point,
or at least an acceptable and
ignored byproduct.
So what's the ultimate strategic
outcome here?
This raises an incredibly
important question for us to
ponder.
What's the ultimate strategic
outcome of this systematic
outsourcing of suffering and
voice?
The author argues that that is
the brutal efficiency of the
modern proxy war.
It achieves strategic goals
while insulating the societies
behind it from the true cost of
their actions.
Efficiency in achieving goals.
Insulation from costs.
It's a system designed quite
explicitly to achieve
geopolitical and strategic
objectives with minimal domestic
political or human capital
expenditure for the external
powers.
The direct human toll, the
generational trauma, the
societal breakdown, the
challenges of post conflict
reconstruction, all of that is
left to others far away.
It's a mechanism for power
projection that has effectively
decoupled the consequences from
the decision makers.
Creating a morally perilous and
critically, A strategically
sustainable for the supporting
powers form of warfare.
This shift can fundamentally
reshape international relations,
potentially making powerful
nations more inclined to
intervention knowing they can
avoid direct accountability.
We've truly taken a deep dive
today into how proxy wars, by
outsourcing the human cost and
isolating societies from the
pain of conflict, effectively
insulate the nation's behind
them from democratic pressure
and traditional accountability
mechanisms.
Yeah, it's a lot to take in.
It's a system designed to keep
the cost minimal at home while
the devastation, the true human
cost, rages elsewhere.
And the idea of the perfect
crime, as Chris Abraham presents
it, isn't necessarily about
malicious intent in the
traditional sense, but about a
system's insidious efficiency.
Efficiency over empathy, maybe?
Perhaps it describes A mechanism
that achieves strategic goals
while cleverly and effectively
bypassing the very domestic
mechanisms, the human cost, the
public outrage, the shared grief
that once forced A reckoning
with the true and terrible price
of conflict.
It's about how the nature of
warfare has evolved to
circumvent the constraints that
previously existed.
The rules of the game have
changed.
In a fundamental way.
So if the historical mechanisms
for ending wars like shared
national grief, public outrage,
and widespread domestic pressure
are effectively neutralized in
proxy conflicts because the pain
is always borne by someone else,
what does that profoundly
unsettling reality imply for the
future of global stability?
It's the big question hanging
over all of this.
What new forms of accountability
might truly be needed, or might
emerge when the pain is entirely
offshored and the hearts and
minds funding these wars are
never genuinely at risk?
A difficult question with no
easy answers.
Something to consider as you
reflect on the conflict shaping
our world and the true cost of
battles waged far from home.